it's been almost two weeks since the
beginning of this impasse we all want
the protest to end and these canadians
to feel like they've been heard and
respected but now critical
infrastructure is being restricted why
because of this prime minister's failure
i've asked the prime minister to meet
with me and the other opposition leaders
in good faith to try to find a way
forward from this impasse he didn't
answer yesterday he hasn't answered to
date i'm going to ask him again will he
meet with us the conservative party of
canada has spent the last two weeks
endorsing and enabling these blockades
across the country the leader of the
conservative party and her team have
been their biggest champions even
promoting their fundraising the
consequences of these actions are having
dire impacts they're impacting trade
they're hurting jobs they're threatening
our economy and they're obstructing our
communities
i am focused on ending it i hope the
leader of the opposition will maintain
her current position and continue to
call for an end to these blockades we
all support vaccines and 90 as he has
said 90 of canadians have been
vaccinated is he suggesting that unless
100 of canadians are vaccinated he's not
even going to consider opening up and
lifting restrictions is that what he's
trying to tell us 90
is good for us and i would say other
countries in the world who have less
vaccine uptake is he saying he's not
going to do anything until 100 of
canadians are vaccinated
you know what helps lift restrictions
you know what helps move beyond
lockdowns
vaccinations
when canadians get vaccinated including
with our vaccine mandates that ensure
the federal public service and anyone
getting on planes or trains are
vaccinated that has helped move forward
keep canadians safe and most importantly
to keep our frontline health workers
who've been heroes during this pandemic
from being overwhelmed